sure all right so um hi everyone welcome
back to the afternoon station uh it's my
great pleasure to introduce the first
speaker um jose cario from university of
oxford jose has worked in various areas
including pde numerical analysis many
practical systems and kinetic theory in
this talk it will give introduction to
the intelligent particle systems and
their applications through sampling or
under optimization enjoy
so thank you very much for the
presentation and interaction and
invitation here it's great to be in
person for the first time after the
pandemic
so um
so today in fact what i would like to do
is a bit of connection with several of
the groups and communities here
represented in this
program so i will
put emphasis in uh both
practical and
pe uh
viewpoints on these and
[Music]
okay so we'll see what it means
okay so let me explain the story from
where we came
and the origin of this kind of methods
so in fact we're in the in the
literature
so many people
looking at
the
problem of consensus
apply to several um
to several fields one of them probably
the most classical one is about opinion
dynamics people were doing in social
sciences models for opinion dynamics
and uh
probably one of them the model that uh
got more attention is a
so-called hustleman and cursing model
which essentially they look like this
this kind of models i mean
essentially the opinion of somebody
is
influencing the opinion of somebody else
with certain weights so uh essentially
the individual eye
is influenced by the opinions of the
others uh with certain weights aij and
this uh
they studied uh
several i mean there are several models
and several
variants of this
to analyze the formation of
strong opinions clusters around
certain uh opinions in the
uh whatever space we are talking about
in opinions bodies
okay so this is one probably one of the
classical examples of this
other one that i got interested in like
10 years ago more than that
12 years ago when i was doing a
sabbatical at ucla i started to work
with undergraduate c models for
collective behavior of individuals or
swarming that it was also referred in
today's case caterpillar in the morning
so essentially what you want to do in
those models
is
to uh
say
try to explain the formation of large
coherent structures
formed by individuals that they move in
some coordinated way so this is
essentially
structured that have been
seen or
reported for insects for birds for
microorganisms
have been used for artificial robots in
control engineering and many other
fields
and basically these models they
incorporate three regions
attraction or three regions of
interaction
some repulsion that we basically
understand very well now with the social
distance
so there is an area in which you don't
want to be too close to others
attraction we are social
so we want to be with others and
alignment is what you want to somehow
mimic or follow the orientation or the
movement of others
okay so i'm going to give you two
examples
of these models one that
was studied quite a lot by the group at
ucla maria rita varsonia and graver
toxin collaborators
essentially
it has
you can look at it as a kind of
neutral-like equations in which all the
biology here is embedded in the shape of
this potential view
essentially you want to model with you
the fact that individuals don't want to
be too too close to each other that
would be uh the repulsion the repulsive
part a short distance of this potential
and at large distance they don't want
they want to in fact be together so
there is an attraction
apart from that there is this term here
that um
its only
road is to fix a crucial speed for the
individuals what you want is that the
all the individuals
they move with the speed and square root
of alpha beta asymptotically
of course they are neutral like
equations so neutral has to be always in
my slides since i moved to the uk it's
my only goal
okay
good
so
as i said these are the two
the two kind of effects just to give you
an example
that's uh
what is usually referred as the most
potential
and you just choose the length scales
and the strengths in the right way you
can cook up potentials that look
biologically reasonable
your passive in the short range
are attractive in the long range with
the choice of science they have the
potential here
okay such a simple model but
there are interesting things that happen
let me run these simulations
these simulations are just
200
random particles chosen with 200 random
velocities for them these are the arrows
and you just follow the movement of them
by following the center of mass
so
for this particular initial date that
you have
at the end this formation what is called
the flock solution
meaning that all the velocities they
have arrived to consensus are moving to
certain direction all the velocities are
equal for everybody
okay
so this is what we usually call flock in
those kind of models so essentially they
have arrived to consensus in vegas
that's the part
while here
it looks like
is
more or less a bit random in fact if you
follow the movement of the center of
mass it's moving around but at a certain
point
i assure you
that
there is something that is happening
already
and then at the end what you have is
this kind of uh stable configuration
which is called the mean solution
so i mean this just to give you an
example of the kind of solutions that
you can have for this very simple model
and in fact what is important for me
today for you to make the connection and
see from where i came to the idea of
optimization is to think in terms of
these consensus in velocity
okay so in fact
one of the models that have been
proposed for consensus in velocity for
flux
was uh introduced by felipe cooker and
steven smale
and
it's very simple idea and very
unrealistic but nevertheless simple
what you're assuming you are in one of
the birds in the flock
and you are assuming that you are able
to instantaneously measure the relative
velocity with everybody else
instantaneously and not only that you
are so smart
that you can calibrate the average that
you take of those
velocity differences
by weights that depends on the distance
okay
and uh in that case well the typical
cougars my model is just the power law
became power law the distance so those
that are far from you come less
for the average
okay so in this particular problem in
fact you can show that
rigorously that for
st goes to infinity depending on the
gamma the gamma is less than one half
that's only good on one half
no matter what the initial data is they
will always flock asymptotically they
will always achieve a stimulus to
infinity moving exponentially fast going
to the right into the same direction
okay
so now let's come back to business that
was a good story after lunch
okay so optimization
good
okay i don't have to convince you but i
have this slide there that this is an
important problem
and that there have been many people
many
different viewpoints in how to
try to compute
uh the minimum of a complicated function
in an efficient way there are i'm
listing some of the ones i know but i'm
sure i'm missing many many of them
okay
so let me
now
take
as an example of those
system methods simulated annealing
simulated annealing was essentially
from a point of view to take advantage
of the fact that you do radian descent
of that function that you want to
minimize
and you are adding a noise
but the noise that you add
has some
variance that depends on time and you
can do
some kind of optimal cooling
shadow for adjusting the temperature
such a way that asymptotically you are
going to put essentially zero noise
to stabilize around the minimum of this
uh
function
okay i think probably even have well it
means that kind of thing
okay
so you are changing the temperature in
such a way that
you make the temperature small so this
is a beta t
such a way that at the end you end up
in the
case maximum of the function
okay
so but what i would like to do
well is to allow for irregular objective
functions that you will see
and i would like to
be uh well in principle this method is
not guaranteed to find the lower minimum
correct if i'm wrong i'm not
the
the most recent i don't know the most
recent results about simulated annealing
how it is the result right now but
there are some advantages and
disadvantages okay of this
okay so
let's summarize this is what we want to
do
and uh
just an example we are thinking in terms
of what the theme of the
also
of the program is is about relations to
machine learning so let's assume that we
have a loss function where we have some
data and then we're taking an average to
do that
so i'm gonna propose you a different
kind of method why not
to use a non-grading method
okay so i'm going to assume for that
assume the gradient is hard to calculate
okay
so
my objective function should not be
necessarily smooth
and we know far that for greater methods
typically they are bad when you have
flat local minimum
okay
why is that this is an observation
that uh
has been done by many authors probably
the ones i know
is that if you look at
the stochastically
descent and you write associated to the
stochastic greater than sent and you
write it's a poker plan equation
for welcome a lot of equations and just
translate them into different names of
different communities
so you know your stationary state is as
you all know the normalized into the
minus beta the loss function
and let's assume that the loss function
has a flat meaning
here and the global minimum in shadow so
there is a theorem that tells you more
or less
that
in certain conditions
it's more likely that your descent
method is going to end up on the flat
local minima than on your
shallow global medium
okay so that's one reason probably want
to try something that doesn't use the
gradient
but there's no integration for instance
it's just too complicated to compute
okay
so uh
yeah well just an example probably
uh but you can cook up an example very
easily
with
the form of a loss function with some
data with a given function
just in one dimension
and uh whose global minimize here and if
you try to use sdd as we need and the
most
naive way
so we got a successful rate of only 18
okay
good i'm going to propose you anyhow a
different
perspective
which is
to
achieve the minimum
by averaging
evaluations
so let me explain the idea and this is
where the idea of consensus enters into
the game
so what i'm assuming is that i'm gonna
follow
explorers so let's think about this we
have butterflies in yosemite
okay i throw the butterflies into
something they have plenty of them they
just go around
and they are able to communicate their
height
okay
so these are my
i
my
t
so
and then
how they interact they interact through
this average that i am defining
i will tell you what is omega f in a sec
omega f is some function that depends on
f and the function i want to minimize
and i'm going to take it's um
it's a
first moment normalized with respect to
omega
so what i'm writing here is first just
pure relaxation towards this average
that depends on all the agents
all the butterflies
and then i put also a noise
that depends on
the uh distance towards that average
in such a way that when
you are close to the average for the
agents the noise is getting smaller and
smaller and do the isotropic the
simplest way
with the models of the distance
okay so this was in fact uh an idea that
i started to discuss with a puzzle of
mine stefan martin
when he was a postdoc in
imperial college
in
2016
and then
he wrote a paper with the
other some collaborators with the
numerical analysis of that
i mean medical experiments mainly
and
we uh look at that
from the theoretical point of view
so i'm gonna work i talked about the
work with john pilchoy claudio
which is essentially
look at if we can prove something about
these consensus consensus-based
optimization the idea of calling it
consensus based is because i'm trying to
do an average or some knowledge of the
function f through this v of t here that
i'm in introducing the evolution of each
individual
okay advantages um
we don't use gradient information at all
so we need to evaluate the function f
so
and many times
so hopefully it's not super expensive
uh
from the more point of view of the math
analysis this will give you a stochastic
process that you have a diffusion that
generates a bft so you have to deal with
that
and you hope to have these um
consensus on this kind of flock behavior
as i
came from
from that
perspective for
the location of the individuals
okay
sorry would you mind saying one more
time that omega f
omega f i'm going to choose it
now
so what's the omega f that i'm gonna
take
no surprise i take e minus beta f
why because i'm thinking at f i'm
thinking about f as the potential of a
gibbs measure
so i'll meet the temperature so i take e
to the minus b times
and now
if would you take e to the minus beta f
what is this other h
essentially
now let's uh try to
get some more intuition by taking the
number of regions going to infinity they
take infinite butterflies
uh hopefully there are
not so many but yes
anyhow we take m to infinity
and what we see here what we get is some
kind of exact what we get is our first
moment of certain
probability measure
so what is the limit i'm taking here of
course
rho t is the limit of the empirical
measure associated to this process where
i take one over n sum of the diracs at x
i of t
assuming that this will converge towards
something that i call roti what i'm
gonna get here is the first moment
of the distribution rho t multiplied by
e to the minus beta f
okay
so
essentially this average i'm taking it
against
this probability measure
mu t beta e to the minus beta multiplied
by rho
okay
and now when it comes into play the idea
that we have with this is in fact that
we knew about the laplace principle that
is known in other communities as we need
well large deviation
but i mean
the last principle essentially
how i'm thinking about it how i'm using
it here is essentially to tell me
that when i send the temperature between
to zero which is beta to infinity
then this quantity minus one over beta
log of this integral
it will converge to the value
at the minimum of the function
okay
as soon as i have essentially the rotis
of solution with respect to leverage
that the x bar is in the support of t
so
what i would like to think is that as
beta goes to infinity
this measure is getting closer and
closer to be
a dirac at the location of the minimum
here for the last principle i assume
that there is a unique minimum and that
will be the assumption on that or all
the time in my talk okay
but
so
how does it work
yeah of course the problem is that this
convergence depends on the donation
right
right i mean
we're gonna talk about this yes yes
let's get to this yes
so
well
i mean this is a
just one example
uh that's the ugly function
and um
[Music]
we're using that with those parameters
that you have only just 10 agents
uh
i'm increasing lambda now
so just for you to see that it happens
what you are expecting you're increasing
land that you're
imposing that the
rental relaxation is faster so
that's so
and now what are the questions
okay
so the questions would be very nice to
know
if we are able to identify for a fixed
number of the agents
the uh n particle distribution
uh
i mean the stationary and partial
distribution sorry the invariant measure
and so we are able to say that when n is
getting to infinity
we get closer and closer to
the the direct delta at the x
bar okay
and would you like to know
how fast the new tn
decay towers uh somehow this product of
the delta d axis and goes to infinity
that the difference goes to zero
okay
so so far
we don't know to how to answer any of
these questions
but what can uh have we have been able
to do until this point is to look at the
mean field limit
so the first thing what we did is okay
let's give an initial justification if
this may work
that's the division if you live in the
equations and let's see if the limited
equation does does the job what it means
is from the
point of view of uh agents it means
essentially to take n to infinity
directly take infinite agents
can we prove that
that we have consensus at the minimum
at the level of the new field equation
okay so
you write formally what's the mean field
limit
of this system
of interacting particles
this is what you get
that's the continuous version
of the
system before
and what's the pde associated to that
and then we are in business i mean from
my point of view
uh
then
what you get is a poker nine equation
where both the drift well i mean in the
drift you have
no no
mystery here the relaxation towards the
average
and here you have a noise
that is
degenerates when it gets
to the average
okay so the question now is can we prove
that this focus plan equation well first
the stochastic process is well defined
and i cannot prove that the focal point
equation
does the job
say they went to infinity under certain
assumptions it converges towards the
data at the minimum of the function
so that's the question that we were able
to solve
so
under certain assumptions
so the assumptions on f that well
obviously i'm going to assume that
i have a minimum and i'm going to assume
that the minimum is positive yes you
just translate the function
and uh i'm going to assume some
local i mean look it's always lipsticks
local electrics but it may grow
a little bit linear at infinity this is
not important you are optimizing anyhow
you can cut outside
the interested area of optimization
and i assume that the there is sporadic
growth at infinity again the same you
can always do that by cutting at the
right place
so under those assumptions
uh i will not enter into the details of
this one can prove
that you have good solutions for this
support
sends an evolution in p2
here
and that's a disclaimer with respect to
this morning this equation is not a
grading flow at all
okay
nevertheless
here uh you use the vaseline too as a
tool to approve the right estimates for
the continuity
to uh
i mean for the stability to
prove the system uh for solutions
okay
so
now we're solving here the pe and
solving numerically in one dimension
okay just
for fun if you want yes to see
and done it for the ugly function
one-dimensional likely function is one
of the typical examples in optimization
lots of local minima one global minimum
i'm not putting the function here i'm
sorry but
you see that the important thing is that
it concentrates
okay and it concentrates at the right
place
okay
so
it's a numerical justification for the
mutual limit
again the multi-limit i uh derive it
formally
theoretically it's more complicated than
if you limit in this case and it will
not enter into life somebody is
interested in it but there is not a
direct application of the standard
theorems for
one yeah so in fact
uh it would be nice to uh also get some
that kind of result at the theoretical
level but what do we look at
is the state empirical measure
the empirical measure is a random
measure
in this case because of the noise
so
uh we did experiments to check
what happens with the expectation
of the
random variable which is the vassal
stein distance between roth yen
and the dirac
at the minimum and also for the variance
so i mean this is encouraging somehow
this is number of particles we were
using by increasing the number of
particles you see that the variance
decreases
okay so that's uh
somehow was the numerical experiment
that we did in order to
make us happy that maybe there is there
was a theorem behind that we had to work
uh okay so as i am telling you the goal
is to show that roti converts to the
dirac
at a point and in fact what i'm gonna
give you ideas and how we did the proof
i'm going to enter into the full detail
what we prove is in fact that roti
converges to a dirac at a point
and that by choosing the parameters
that we have lambda beta sigma
mainly beta large enough
which means the temperature
is small enough
then as t goes to infinity
um
well the x bar
compares to the dirac as they go to
infinity and the x hat sorry
is in a ball of radius epsilon of the uh
of the uh
minimum
and you can get the epsilon as small as
you want by taking the beta as large as
you want
we don't get an explicit rate
okay we just get a result that tells me
that for beta large enough i can
get the point to be as close as i want
to the minimum
yes clarify so in this limit towards
delta uh beta is going to infinity
yeah beta is going to infinity along the
ah no no no we are not moving beta this
is beta fix
and even with fixed data it goes to zero
delta yes
that's the point
the question is that the beta we then
use it to be close to
where we want
yes that's right
no it's not constructive
no no i don't know
and did you run some experiments if you
actually just put beta equals like your
pt is the minimum of the current point
of the current set of points yeah it
would take beta latching we uh
it still works yes i mean beta infinity
we don't have to no we cannot take b to
infinity
dt is the argument the question
ah
yeah you see what you mean
now that that that has more
that has more more issues
yeah no i i no no with the stack value
no
no
that case i cannot make it um
the s hat is going to be in fact the
limit of the average
as t goes to infinity this is what uh
this is what is going to be in the proof
yes hat and what i can say is that the x
hat is going to be as close as a you
want to the minimum a bit as large is it
clearer now
but you don't know that except is the
mean of some exposure no no no we don't
know anything else than this it's just
the limit of the average
and that the that limit is
if we choose the beta large is close
okay
okay so how it goes
and um just to give you a hint of the
proof because i think it it also uh
it gives the idea how how
it works
so i mean
we we compute the evolution of the
variance of rho t
so
that's just the second moment uh around
the
mean of roti
and then you
get this expression
and i want you to make emphasis i want
to make emphasis on two points here the
dimensional dependence here
and here we get the average with respect
to the gibbs
e to the minus beta f rho okay so we
have to relate this kind of quantity
with that with the variance if we want
to do something here
and let's assume that we are already
very close i mean just to give you an
idea let's assume that we are already
very close to the minimum okay so uh
somehow that the f is being between f
sub f which means the minimum and the
sup of f and let's assume that that
difference is small okay
so
then
you can just um
uh bound by uh kind of uh jensen
this quantity in terms of the variance
by by this quantity okay
and then what you see
is that
if you allow i mean let me call this i
mean it's not the same episode as before
but let me call this quantity epsilon i
should have called it differently so if
you take lambda larger than d sigma
squared multiplied by that quantity you
are going to get that the variance
decays exponentially fast
okay
which is already a good indication it
goes to zero t goes to infinity this is
what you want
okay
so in lambda is larger than this ema
square times something
then
this should tell you that the variance
goes to zero but in fact this implies
that the uh
average that i'm doing that i'm using
for the um
for the method
and the expectation of rho also converts
towards each other as t goes to infinity
okay
and i'm going to show you
a little bit on that and i need in order
to do that i need more assumptions
so as i told you before i assume always
that the influence is positive i'm going
to assume now
smoothness
and this is where you're interested in
the proof i need a smoothness uh second
derivative of f
and since the i n and rd i need this but
again
uh these assumptions if we were to use
it in practice you can always assume it
because you cut outside a big ball
and this is not important or important
thing the important thing is the
smoothness
okay
so
in fact i don't want to bother too much
with all the constants here but did you
choose now the lambda the sigma
in a way and the beta in a way that you
have these relations with the c's that
appear here
and with the variance initially
with the l1
[Music]
the l1 norm of e to the minus beta f
with respect to run out initially they
entered that's the initial values that
enter into this
then
you can uh
get
as i said in general that the variance
decays exponentially fast this is more
general than the previous one in which i
was saying that it was local
so one can do that uh more globally and
still you have to deviate the case
exponentially
okay
so that's the the core of i mean the
core lemma to prove
once you have that
you look at the evolution of the
expectation of rho
is given by the quantity and this
quantity because of the variance the
case exponentially fast
is interval in time
so this means
that this expectation has a limit
so that's where i'm getting that i have
a limit
uh
this average that's the ostensing
so
once i have a limit
the question is
you have to really prove that that
quantity then converges to
e to the minus beta f at the delta sorry
about the hat and now it's tilde okay
the limit
now
now we have achieved the consensus now
we have done that under certain
assumptions on the choice of the
parameters
now is where it enters to choose beta
and beta is where we use the laplace
so for doing laplace and
one
has to be careful with this
and uh it enters also the value
initially this is where the initial
distribution plays a role
so
so anyhow with the laplace principle
plus the evolution of that quantity
and i will not enter into details you
can show
that
then
you will have
these
well you will have this kind of control
on on this
quantity and uh precisely this is what
laplace tells you is that you can choose
beta large enough in such a way that
this difference towards the minimum is
uh small
so this together with that implies what
i said
that uh dx tilde here is close as close
as i want by choosing beta large enough
to the x bar
okay just to give you the the the steps
without entering two details
so one has to do also uh
a little bit more cumbersome argument at
the end with the laplace principle
so this tells you then
the method works with n equals infinity
but no rate of decay i don't have any
rate of decay here
um
okay let me uh
now is it clear up to this point
more or less
okay now let me give you some variants
so another variant that we have done
well
yeah and just reminding you again the
same thing
and just to give you um another
uh
variance that people have done
so
one variant of course is uh to avoid uh
very much in the spirit of the positive
part of the energy this morning for
katie
why to go in directions where the loss
function is increasing so you can always
put a cut off when the difference of the
values
goes in the wrong direction and makes it
faster
but
that's not the point i want to make here
i come back i came back to the
finite dimensional
case to the discrete case in a sense
and now i want to make the point that
remember that i had to choose
the lambda of order the dimension for my
theorem to be applicable so lambda had
to be something like d times sigma
squared something like that
so obviously we were not happy with that
essentially you want to use that for
machine learning problems
it's not going to be the the case
okay so can we do some variant of it
so
let me show you the first improvement
that we did in order to avoid the
dimensionality
and then also in terms of efficiency of
the numerical method
this part of uh
of the work i did it in collaboration
with xi jin
laylee and yuhu adu
hua is also participating in the program
but
she will be here tomorrow okay
and it will help also in the
in the group and the seminar group that
we have
okay so what's the first improvement
that we have done choose a different
type of noise
and i will explain you in a second why
we did an isotropic noise
so what we did uh what we thought is why
don't we do
relaxations
again in the noise term we put
the generator degeneracy to go in the
direction
of the average now the notation change
okay sorry for that x bar star is the
the average that i was doing with the e
to the minus b to f
so
i do that but instead of doing with the
modulus i'm gonna do it with independent
motions in each of the components so
component wise
okay
why i do this
well intuitively you could say
uh
that now
this will allow to explore more the
dimension in each each dimension with
different rates but the fact
is that we thought in terms of the
estimate
let me show you the in the first
cbo
model
this was essentially the estimate that
enters so i mean just to simplify
everything this has to be the average i
mean sorry the yes the average i was
computing
um
[Music]
here with the average but let's do it
just with a constant to see the
dependence on dimension so it will
repeat with a constant what happens with
the decay of this
when you have just a a constant and not
the average
so well for each dimension you have that
so you do the algebra
it formulas the expectations some of the
dimensions i mean you can do that with
pd's too just by just writing pde
compute them a moment and so on you end
up in this and
that's precisely where the dimension
enters
when you add here you are adding
these you know in each component and
then you get minus two lambda plus sigma
square d so you need that kind of
condition
okay
so now what uh we did here
was essentially by doing it component
wise
the big difference is that now when you
sum
you recover now the full expectation
here without the dimension
so now the
const the uh condition that you need
doesn't depend on dimension
okay
well
if you go to the
theorem that we proved before and you
just change this fact
the the proof applies equally well
okay modulus some
little lemma that we had to add
but essentially the same proof gives you
also the convergence of this guy in the
same kind of result but now there is no
dimension dependent
okay
uh
what about the cost
of the numerical method
uh ah yes well
i mean just to write again
the mean field limit of this one will
correspond to this kind of machine blast
of the equation like machine glass of
light equation you can write again the
pde you want
and essentially uh the theorem at the
end we made it a little bit more
explicit in terms of the initial value
of the loss function
and the dependence on beta so
essentially you can take beta large
enough under those conditions in such a
way that you are at a distance one over
beta
okay
well i mean here you will see that the
dependence on the initial value and the
dependence on beta
for the numerical method as i was saying
before
we tried also to improve it why because
you're taking the average it's an
interactive particle system so you look
at the cost that you have in terms of
the number of particles each um each
evaluation
i mean each uh
you do some kind of um
implicit something or explicit oil or
whatever anyhow you will have a order of
n square to compute because you have
these double sums
so we also thought in terms of improving
this
and i'm not going to discuss too much
here
but these
comes from a recent series of papers of
xi jin
and collaborators that started with a
paper of xi jin
laylee and jango liu
they introduced the so-called random
batch method for
interacting particle systems
and
they propose
um
and they gave quantitative bounds also
for this interacting particle system on
the error that you commit by
doing this kind of procedure here we
didn't study the error that we commit
but let me just explain you what is this
random batch method
almost the the words say what it is
so let's count
what we need to do
okay so we have to calculate the value
of a function i want to minimize
and typically in machine learning is
something like that so you will need
this order of the number of data that
you have kind of
the weighted average that you need to do
is of order capital n number of
particles
so the order of
computation is going to be like that
good so might be very heavy especially
if you are in uh
with lots of data here or with many
particles that is where we know that
it's becoming better than the
model
okay so what we do instead is we
generate m particles initially
and we
at each step what we do is to update
only m particles out of those n
and at the level of the evaluation of l
again you choose a batch a group of
particles in which you are going to use
for both
the evaluation
and the sums here
okay and you choose them randomly at
each
iteration
okay
that becomes of order m because that's
the size of the small batch
the same thing here as i said so it's
becoming little om
so then
you make it
order one
okay
for the random batch method as i said
i don't have estimates on the error they
have done estimates on the error the
random batch method for basic
mckim blassov equation
uh it would be it's a very interesting
open problem
okay
it would be nice because it's a way of
making efficient
of these kind of things
anyhow this is what we did
yeah no at the end of the day capital m
and little m are much smaller so
essentially uh these little m times
capital m is like order one
is what i mean by that
you see because
that could be uh i don't know you can
make the update of only two
say okay
good
so
well i mean
we did the same example as with the
stochastic gradient descent for that
particular case with the flat that uh
the stochastic gradient in the sentence
is simplest form it wasn't working too
well i'm sure you can make it much
better than that by doing any of the
other variations and improvements
but with this method
well you get it
success rate 98
with 100 particles and with the batch
being 20.
okay so you update only 20 of them in
each
iteration
okay so that's so what i wanted to say
on that optimization side
yes
uh i mean these examples in one
dimension
i was explaining in general i mean it's
just a sample
the simulation sure sure is this is this
function
just in one dimension we did uh we
didn't in the paper
we didn't do a
complete comparison with other things
because
yeah you know
no we didn't do that to study
if you are interested in a more
realistic
we did that and i had it in a slide that
i have at the end
i can show it now or show it at the end
to you
but we did like uh unleashed data set
a real
typical example
for for
this kind of uh neural networks
and we uh
computed the parameters of a relu
7
400
parameters
and uh essentially with the same kind of
idea
okay
in those larger
examples how were you choosing
oh very small because if not
yeah m uh very very small because if not
it's not feasible i i can show you the
results later you're interested in on
this
yeah so what you've got here is that
expectation by taking the random
variable
normal
what do you mean
based on the random variable x hat
so each time we do the evaluation yes so
we just generated this by uh with
certain value of n that i don't remember
now
yes yes
okay so how much do i have left
okay
so
the last part i wanted just to briefly
mention about ideas that we have done
very recently this is just a work we
finished before summer so in july
in collaboration with uh
frank hoffman that is going to be also
in the program
andrew stewart and uh we're gonna advise
um
so
uh because uh the i mean the question
came naturally
uh
because uh andrew has been working many
many years on using ensembl kamen
filters and somewhat common inversion
which are derivative-free
algorithms to do inversion problems
so his question was can one
adapt your ideas to produce something of
that sort that does something for by yes
an inference that was his question
so we started to work on that
last
yeah the previous time i was in
california
which was the last trip i did
internationally before the pandemic
okay so
and i'm going to tell you a little bit
about that
so let me see if i would
but
we will i mean this one it can be
discussed in the group if you are
interested in
i'm sure franco will be very happy to do
that
okay so
um
let me set up the inverse problem that
we want to solve okay
so i i know that is a bit changing gears
but you will see the connection and the
idea but i need to set up now a little
bit of notation for that
so
here
theta are the parameters
and uh g is what is called usually the
the the the forward map you have the the
data
and the data are given by the ys and
then you have some noise in the data
okay
so essentially what you want to
calibrate are the parameters
and here again we will be thinking in
terms of derivatives of g are not
available
and g even is expensive to evaluate so
we want to to do the
minimal evaluations we can
also on g
okay
so
let's uh formulate that as an
optimization problem
first
you can think in terms of finding the
best choice of the parameters theta star
by minimizing
this function
okay so just
the difference between the data and the
the
forward map geo theta
in just to clean the norm and then plus
a term that
it comes from from the noise
okay
so essentially and probably i don't have
to mention many of this to many people
in the room
they know much more than me for this
so
in the radiation approach what you are
essentially doing
is these assumptions you have a prior
distribution for the parameters that you
assume
is normal with some variance
covariance metrics
like live hood is what we are assuming
that we have the noise on the
on the uh
between the the data and the
map
with respect to the parameters
and then the posterior you just computed
with base
theorem
you just write that the probability of
theta condition 2i is given by that and
then
is proportional to this product that's
how you get that is exponentially to the
minus beta f of theta okay
good
so
the question now would be
can we
generate approximate samples from
e to the minus f
okay
or i mean you can give the maximum
probability point by
uh finding the minimizer of f that could
be also
if you think in terms of optimization
well
so we call it the
consensus-based sampling the method
let me explain you the idea
here again it's very similar to what
in
the intuition is very similar to what i
was explaining you
we want to compute
other edges
of
the row multiplied by the gibbs e to the
minus beta f
so we take this as the the empirical
sorry the probability measures
times e to the minus beta f normalized
and we can we use
now its mean as before different
notation again
and its variance
okay
and um well just for uh formulas that
may appear later
the if i just use without the beta means
that the the
m of mu is the mean of the
measure mu and
c of mu is the covariance matrix of the
[Music]
probability measurement okay
so
the discrete version
uh the mckin kind of difference
equations that we use
is again a relaxation towards the
average as before as i used for the
optimization
but now the noise
i'm choosing i'm using the body the
variance itself with respect to again
this
probability measure so in changing the
noise
and modulating the noise if you want
with suitable parameters
with the
covariance metrics
okay i have to tell you that this is not
the way in which i thought about it i
started thinking about the pd and then
we wrote the discrete version of it also
because andrew asked me no i want the
discreet version of it
okay fine let's let's find a description
of it
so um for him it's much better to think
in these terms but
okay
so
you see again the advantage of this
is that there is no derivative
good
let's write the continuous version
uh that everybody is on the same
page no matter the community where you
come now i'm writing the continuous
version as an sd
so what i'm telling you is that i'm
taking the the relaxation towards the
average average with respect to the e
minus beta f row
and the covariance matrix has a factor
of scaling factor i will discuss in a
sec one over lambda times the covariance
so what's the motivation for not using
the difference between teacher and the
mean in front of the noise but using the
covariance major
and the mean respect for the noise
to have the
i mean the intuition we we thought is
because um
in any case we were just before the
average towards the mean so we were not
taking into account the expansion of the
distribution or let's say that they are
symmetry in different directions of
abortion like you have aggression with
one value which is matches
with one of the direction which is much
more squeezed than the other you say
what i mean you want to avoid
yeah and also
that's a that's at the point that this
lambda is to avoid to avoid the collapse
i'm going to get to that in a second but
uh the the choice of this is independent
of the lambda because we can use also
i mean what he's asking about the
collapse is
how can i avoid now that this goes again
to a direct so it's this lambda that
place the the row for that
okay
so that's uh the
i mean associated to this the e you can
write the pde i mean uh
it will be written in a second i don't
know why i didn't put it just after
okay so let me just to give notations
and uh if i go back to the discrete
version i have two parameters beta and
this alpha here
okay
uh the alpha to take the continuous
version what i did is to think about
alpha as e to the minus lambda t and
then take lambda equal into zero and
that is how you get this one
okay
and um
so what are the two
the two uh
methods that you can get out of this
so if you choose land equals one and
this goes in the direction of what leon
was asking me
this is what uh is the optimization mode
in the sense that you will see that then
this case we get again the concentration
to adidas
well if you choose lambda
depending on the the temperature
then you avoid the collapse and then you
convert towards uh
something
uh well that's uh what uh we prove in
some of the cases
okay the first thing is
uh in fact let me just explain you that
fixed points uh stationary states are
independent of alpha and in fact they
are gaussians
you can compute them
in particular cases
um
even explicitly so i will come back to
that they are always questions anyhow
but
also at the continuous level
this is the evolution of the mean and
the variance is
with respect to the mean and the
variance of the gives so you have to
work to
see what happens with this and still
goes to infinity
but just to give you an example if you
choose the the simplest one so you take
the linear forward map
so
essentially your f is quadratic with a
matrix there so you can compute all of
this explicitly your stationary state
is a gaussian with this mean
and these covariance matrix
so you see now the role of the lambda
if i choose the lambda
well enough in terms of beta i avoid the
collapse i can choose lambda group 1 i
will get the collapse
and um
yes with this
i'm getting out of uh
almost
so um
yeah well i did i promised that i would
like to write the pd
so uh here it is
there's the pd oh no no i don't have it
here oh my pd
is there
and uh let me
mention that at the continuing time
dynamics
so we are starting essentially uh with
this kind of method so we have studied a
lot the decay rate of the discrete
versions because this is what android
stuart was originally more interested in
it but we haven't looked at that much
about the london asymptotics of the pde
and rates of convergence of the pd and
other properties
just because
we started to solve
one question at the time but uh
yes to finish
probably
i want to finish with uh that you see it
in action
so again um if you use an optimization
mode that's either the ugly function or
the restringing function two typical
examples in optimization with lots of
local minima
so
here
it works perfect
so you see how
nicely it works in terms of optimization
too
so essentially
here the difference between the two is
the alpha that one is closer to the
alpha equals zero that is closer to the
continuing version the uh alpha close to
one
um
yeah just for you to say it but uh of
course there are plenty of discussions
in the prep print and we can discuss
that
uh about the decay rates and so on for
sampling
we use this as a one-dimensional problem
for sampling
so what you do
is to solve that
elliptic value value problem in one
dimension
where your
data
are just evaluations of
the functions and known at two points
so it's a very typical uh test case that
understood was using for a while
and uh let me show you one just one
simulation
so this is the case of uh sampling when
the lambda is uh less than one
so what you get again your agents your
butterflies are approaching the
posterior
and uh yeah well they're getting better
and better and better
and getting closer to the posterior this
is what you want
uh of course this is uh this is with
beta fix we never change beta and there
are many improvements that we do also in
the paper by changing the data and added
the skill level and analyzing that
so that gives you an idea of what we are
doing in that and thank you
[Applause]
for any questions
yes thanks listen for this very
interesting talk uh have you considered
choosing meter time dependent for which
is proportional to time
you get closer to the real minimum as
time proceeds
that's a very good idea i mean that's
like the cooling schedule for the
simulated annealing we haven't studied
that and
that would that's a very natural
question
i agree
so since i have you i i i have this
question about how this
particular choice of the equation let's
talk about the optimization one first
okay that was fine uh came to be right
so okay you have this consensus and you
want to have a term that basically says
i want them to collapse so i'm going to
actually have like some you know
uh the the variance of this thing
and you did you know all these terms
look natural and i wanted to know if you
investigated other terms is there like
is there any hope to actually have a
similar behavior where you have a term
that just you know or the variant
collapses that you put in front of your
uh of your uh uh ground motion that
would be a
a gradient flow in vascular spine for
example so somehow like when you write
the clocker plank equation there's this
great term that i wonder if you can just
try to play around and see if you could
actually modify this variance term so
that it would actually be some very
inflow and have some velocities in there
i had to say that uh no we haven't done
that
yet but uh what we i can say is that we
look at for instance in the case of
isotropic noise it's very natural
question because i mean you can invent
whatever you want at the end of the day
it's your objective uh the important
thing here there is no physics that you
have to follow i totally agree so if you
put the the we
for instance we investigated in the
noise term instead of modulus of uh
period moles to a power
and um
didn't change that much uh the results
and we didn't see any advantage in fact
it was making it more difficult from the
math viewpoint if the power was a bit
larger than
i remember they fits too i think
um
so i mean we haven't no i i agree with
you and we haven't explored all of these
things so i'm happy to
to discuss
yeah we haven't explored as i mean this
is as much as we we know
so any other questions
just out of curiosity um how did you
prove existence to this
equation
a it's just a fixed point argument
honestly on the uh paths in w2 is an
uninspiring response like that
uh by hand uh priority estimates
from moments
and then keeps point at the level of the
sd
that there is where this power enters
that makes our life difficult
problems that you are trying to solve
here we know are in full generality
their computational heart they are
interacting so
what is the
hope here is there a hope of uh
finding some subclass that destructible
if you just saw like what is the best we
can hope to improve yeah
that goes in the direction of a
deficiency of the algorithm that i was
discussing at some point with a random
batch and so on that is what it makes it
feasible for a large dimensional problem
okay uh but for that we don't have a
theory underpinning the any kind of uh
error estimate that we do but
i mean the results uh as we were saying
before i mean i had them over here you
know
yeah okay that
so uh
so this is the uh mnist data set with
two layers neural network
your uh uh dimension is 7290
uh we use m
100 points
m equals 10 is the batch
so we update 10 randomly chosen
particles at each iteration
and uh well we were looking at this
typical graph that
appears in many papers in terms of what
is called number of epochs
and now compare the different these are
different choices of the
uh
of the uh
number of uh
one of them is exactly that one and the
other two are other choices of n m so
you can do that uh would you get uh you
can compare to the success rate that's
the success rate the accuracy on the
test data
so
it's just um you can use it but uh again
we haven't explored that much
uh this
you could run it on something it's a
zeroth order uh uh thing right so we
don't have that many tools available
from zeroth order optimization so you
could even try to prove stuff for like
convex optimization right
and with xerox order rather than doing
the
point gradient
but in fact that's also a thing that i'm
interested in learning what are the
interesting problems from your point of
view guys
yeah do you have more questions maybe
you could ask for him
so thank you thank you for the very nice
talk
[Applause]
so
[Music]
i